[Music]
[Music]
and gases and docks
[Music]
dolphins dolphins and an awesome awesome
dog food dog asses and dogs and dogs and
gases and pass
oh that was a nice thing to hear
[Music]
[Music]
Frank
[Music]
[Music]
Frank
[Music]
[Music]
I
Spencer
[Music]
recommendation
oh my god dude substrate always be 94 no
such dream
[Music]
bring a populist Facebook page too
[Music]
I'm a cyclist
[Music]
Brent I populace Facebook greatest of
all
I was like cockiness potion amazing
stuff
[Music]
[Music]
69 now it's time for new believable
people and we must do it if we don't
control insiders this will be over and
over to lead it by an anti common ground
to halt the spread of lies and we must
do it big fat love inside common ground
to halt the spread of lies fatal we want
to build a much better believable people
and we must do it not fatal
communication very much higher America
first to lead it by an any insiders
fighting for insiders time to stop
ciders fighting for insiders more of
insiders fighting for insiders time to
stop insiders fighting for insiders a
baron come first today
[Music]
good morning mug it's a little bit
different I don't know if we have the
Slurpee intro but we're actually on
location in Deep Ellum quarterback
Garrett yes sir deep deep alum Dallas
where we've actually found the cure for
kovat 19 violent riots so who'd have
thought
it's an antibody of sorts listen we're
doing something a little bit different
wanted to show you what it's like listen
hashtag not all white people okay
those were just bad drivers don't indict
the entire race based on guys in a Chevy
I just want to take you guys through
here and show you a little bit of what's
going on the neighborhood it's a we've
been hearing a lot that these these
riots are peaceful I don't know about
you I won't call it a protest here's my
question is my question honestly when
they say these are peaceful protests I
saw a chanc weigert man I don't want to
talk I don't want a resurrect a dead but
he said you know this is some looting I
wouldn't say right at this point if
these aren't riots and you'll see some
of the damage here and what bit what
precautions business owners have had to
take can you tell me I want you to
comment this is my question of the day
if these aren't riots what is can you
think of anything that would be
considered a riot if not what's going on
right now across the country certainly
this length of time I mean really have
soccer riots every now and then people
get mad that you know they're their club
captain is I don't what's this what is
it Manny is Colombian do you anything
about soccer no no you're straight right
so okay let's show you a little bit as
to what's going on here then we'll also
talk obviously about some things last
night four police officers were shot
James is a James Scurlock what's his
name Scurlock I believe was James
Scurlock is the new hoax that's been
going on of course people are using
using the death of James Scurlock as a
call for justice and listen I want fewer
deaths across the board I see this
coming in coming to a fever pitch but we
do need to be accurate about what these
deaths are and why people
and what's weird is that guy put he
amplified his card and it's an old
shitty car like a mother okay well you
know we just saw the 98 98 Chevy so as
you can see here these are and what will
walk the Main Street these are business
owners business shops and let's make
sure we show this everywhere they're
boarded up and keep in mind what this
means is that either these windows were
broken in kicked in bricks whatever it
is there were pallets of bricks here in
Dallas Texas or they were afraid that
they were about to be broken and
somebody that I would like to show you
that I think is pretty interesting here
now to be clear I think that these were
here before the riots hashtag riots not
protestors I don't know you're gonna see
ease oh hello sir sorry we're we're
filming but I know you didn't want to be
on camera thank you so this gentleman
actually lives here and he takes
precautions to save his area and he is
he was telling us was very very loud
pretty unruly here last night that's
giving one of our producers look at him
he walks with no fear white privilege
let's take you around the neighborhood a
little bit and before we show you
everything that's going on you know I
see a lot of people in media get this
wrong so much wrong and it's tough
because I haven't Mabel to have my black
rifle coffee this morning so I had a dr.
pepper
by the way ladders credit calm no black
rifle that cuppa coffee calm flash card
I haven't a caffeine this is a really
bad idea people are saying well you know
what this is what we have to do because
peaceful protests are in a lot when when
Colin Kaepernick peacefully protest you
tell him to shut up no no no one has a
problem with Colin Kaepernick going to a
park and taking a knee people need to be
clear the problem there wasn't with a
peaceful protest the problem there was
with a man who was paid to play football
hijacking a multi-million dollar job to
make a political statement and people
have the right to vote with their
dollars not support Colin Kaepernick
look at this right here you can clearly
see this was just to be just to be clear
before I've been here before it was not
an indoor outdoor patio it was black
lives matter riots and I do want people
to call this out it's not an tyfa
certainly not white supremacist and i
know that there are just people looking
to loot their crumb
were looking to blend in black lives
matter needs to be called out as a
terrorist organization at this point the
leaders need to be called out at this
point there needs to be outright
condemnation of the riots as well as
assisting business owners and I don't
mean a couple we've seen some really you
know heartening footage of black
protesters who are out there helping
business owners but the leadership of
black men lives matter need to help
rebuild these businesses oh I think she
saw the cameras and she was she was
spooked hello hi how are you that's okay
so these these are all boarded up here
did you guys do this just last night or
how long have they been boarded up they
got say they get smashed
Wow and were you here when that happened
okay good
all right and you guys planning on
shutting down here tonight pretty early
to 5:00 okay
well typically I would imagine that's
early for a bar right record it hang
okay so what what's five hours of
business all right thank you be safe
together we will see it through all
right that pisses me off I guess we can
go with that you know I see people
talking about Christians as well you
know listen we just need to be peaceful
and you see these police officers in
Flint who Neal did you see by the way
did you see those white guys who kneeled
and asked for forgiveness
that's not good but by the way keep in
mind how racist that is right
asking white people all white people to
kneel and ask for forgiveness could you
imagine if white people asked all black
people to kneel and ask for forgiveness
for the cops who were shot last night
cuz again some of them were shot by
white people I understand it but not all
white people certainly not in 2020 are
guilty of the sin of slavery as far as
what I am I going to kneel and a sign of
peace to de-escalate no I'm not going to
kneel and ask for forgiveness for
something that I've never done but I
would like to sit down and talk with
people I would like to sit down and hear
what the grievances are and what the
goal is with this the First Amendment
allows you the right to protest but that
also it requires
now requires it should necessitate
petitioning right the right to protest
in particular what are they petitioning
justice okay Derrick Chauvin was charged
with third-degree murder they're
investigating the other police officers
and by the way from the top down from
Donald Trump said not justice what do
you put I did do you need him to be hung
from the gallows do we want to go back
to the to the pre slavery or during
slavery type executions what well I'd
understand what justice is being
demanded I see all of these requests on
Twitter well we have one simple request
that officers stop killing black people
but apparently that's too complicated
what what does what does that even mean
that black officers stopped killing the
officer stopped killing black what about
white officers and black officer said
what about black officers who killed
white people do you see that one
yesterday the black cop black cop who
there was this angry black lady who was
punching a white police officer in the
face the white police officer did
nothing he can go find this at TMZ and
she'd punched him again and then a black
officer knocked her unconscious or as I
call it a happy ending at that point you
know why that you know why that officer
did that because he knew that that if
that white officer responded to a woman
who was pummeling him he would be the
next direction and again all of us all
of us were absolutely appalled at what
we saw in that video we were appalled
but guess what you lost the argument
because now everyone is appalled at this
when you start burning cities and you
have a complicit media we're still all
good
open seems to be a disconnect mean
language talk about all as well
Charlie Brown the Reese the HP mom that
you know what bothers me most of all is
you can just tell by this menu that
these privileged white hipsters are
still gonna go out there in solidarity
after the shit's been broken yeah
french fried ben gets they've been yet
that means donut by the way to be clear
in french that's one of those things
like oh I like gelato I mean means ice
cream and Italian creme glass see that's
just by the way lingerie is not a word
in French I just say it cuz I'm pissed
from all this affected bull crap going
on Dallas pinup Hey look at that
why not on the black lives matter thing
what is the pinup thing such a cool deal
with hipsters like I was in a rock
ability I remember that started for a
while right but was there ever a time
where there was a more sexist beauty
standard for women you had to have a 25
inch waist and double D's if you look at
Betty you look at Betty Boop you look at
pinup what was it Rob Rock well the girl
in the rocket the bombshells bombshells
but for some reason another problem I
can't believe your unrealistic standards
of beauty hi how are you just so what do
you think just going to work trying to
stay safe stay safe I don't think she
likes me very much
now again just showing you what's going
on this neighborhood peaceful protest
guys peaceful protest you know where
they didn't have to do this when I think
Trevor Noah was saying well I don't know
how you can be mad at these people when
they're protesting than that what he
said he was saying you know how do you
expect them to protest I've on a second
I remember when the Tea Party protested
in the same manner in Cooper who
yesterday was livid about our president
talking about the insurrection act
referred to them as tea baggers right
they mocked all of the tea party
protesters and that was really about an
encroachment of government I don't wear
any boards having to go up we just
walked past a block and a half there's
not a single business that hasn't had
their windows kicked in
you know as a matter of fact they went
around and made the cities cleaner than
they left them with the tea parties they
showed up with pokey sticks I don't know
what they're called and they were
picking trash up and then the media said
look they're trying to stab minorities
with pokey sticks so how about that it's
not as that we don't have examples we
sound like we don't have examples of how
to protest peacefully you know what
soma [ __ ] how about that you know who
loves MLK white people and black people
alike you know H rioters white people
and black people alike what really
concerns me is when you see this right
now and you look at this and the media
says this is largely peaceful what does
that mean what does that mean the media
is tacitly endorsing it right saying
this is a rage we need to listen to them
and what does that do well unfortunately
for young people it breeds more racism
and I tell you this right now because
there are a lot of white faces there
lordís a Dallas strong is there anything
more ironic then people having to put up
boards because windows have been smashed
in and then peace love equality I hope
by the way I hope this reframes the
whole flowerpower hippie era wasn't
nearly as violent this as this but the
idea that cops just descended on a bunch
of drum circle hippies smoke and pot no
that's not exactly what happened I think
a few folks knew exactly what was going
on that iconic picture of the Daisy
going into the rifle many people would
like to see that Daisy going through the
back of his palm if you knew what was
happening on what they were doing with
police officers and I don't think I've
ever seen it worse than this right now
peace love equality this ISM this is
almost a perfect encapsulation of the
media right now right
smash it doesn't matter if it's a black
business owner or a white business owner
smash it personal property sure maybe
it's insured maybe it's not insured how
long does it take to rebuild smash it
then the media says you need to listen
to these people you need to listen why
are you angry this is largely a peaceful
protest look they wrote peace well I'm
convinced let's keep going
and then was it James Scurlock this is
the other hoax that's going on right now
again keep in mind everyone here you're
seeing every every single person in the
studio every single person I knew
furious with what happened with George
Floyd doesn't matter that he had
fentanyl and meth in his system and
likely had all kinds of other
complications and he wasn't killed by
the knee on the neck the knee shouldn't
have been on the neck for that long
every single person agrees but now we're
at the point where they're pushing other
hoaxes to try and demand justice justice
for ferb was a Jake Scurlock oh yeah
right here this is one they didn't
manage so this must have been broken
last night because they weren't able to
board it up yet hey you know a OC looks
at this cuz she's from the Bronx and
goes I don't see what does is that's a
creative I thought it was a decorative
choice right isn't it isn't it content
isn't it contemporary shitheel
I believe that's that's the terminology
that's all Bronx is is bombed out maybe
she's from she's from Bronxville I think
she has an expensive home I could be
wrong
what about this person who owns us we
want the guys to put nails on his fence
they not matter are they you can the
media has a disconnect you can tell
people to listen but if they're watching
people burn down and destroy their crap
it's pretty hard to listen to the
message you don't show up and put a gun
to someone's head and then say hey let's
talk peacefully that's not how this
works and I'm sorry we cannot have
democracy and we can not come to the
table when with a gun to our head you do
not negotiate with tears
Scurlock so the story was there at my
cigar window when they don't have coffee
I have a morning breakfast to go I'll
have to light that back in a second well
we'll toss the quarter black here what's
going on Tim your motioning me are you
doing like pitches the camera man you
sure he's doing this he's going like I
don't think I'm gonna do a speedball um
it's a Scurlock was a trend everywhere
well I looked into it and the guy who
shot him was dismissed without charges
now the guy who shot him may be an
[ __ ] I don't know people were saying
as a racist before maybe that's true I
have no idea
but it was dismissed without charges and
then people were protesting and rioting
over this new hate crime well the video
footage from the club revealed that
three men were on top of this man I
think it was a came from a name of the
guard Gardner Gardner was a guy he shot
in my thing punching him ripped
pummeling him senselessly without mercy
you can see in that footage the guy
takes out his gun bang bang fires two
shots into the air to scare them off
those guys run off as he gets up
Scurlock the innocent man of course who
for whom we need to seek justice tackles
him and starts beating him again so now
we're at the second time he fired
warning shots to scare people off then
when he was mounted a second time and
pummeled his head to dribble like a
basketball into the concrete he shot him
and so of course the police looked at it
and said well listen you know this man
was fearing for his life which I think
is a reasonable defense at that point
and he was like free and the rioters
right now we're gonna break [ __ ] unless
that man is put behind bars do you know
what that what that message sends we say
what we need to listen to these people
okay I've listened do you know what I've
heard do you know what effort I've heard
that you want to you want to pouch
pummel dribble my head off the concrete
and after warning shots when you pounced
on me again and beat me I have no right
to defend myself or I should be behind
bars guess what that's not a message eh
it's not a message I care to hear it's
not one that I empathize with and then
what right now we're looking at you know
Donald Trump came out which by there was
just hilarious him holding the Bible and
point out I mean you know what that was
that was because people said he wasn't
doing a whole lot and he wasn't he was
tweeting from his bunker so he wanted to
show strength apparently apparently shot
some apparently secret service shot some
protesters with rubber bullets or
teargas
to clear the way so he could hand stay
in there with the Bible I don't even you
read a verse so anyway terrible photo oh
it's hot this Bible is burning my face
is it hot to you is the Bible
temperature hot not spicy but actually
physically hot when we have a president
who's talking about the insurrection act
and I will say this I'm becoming less
and less libertarian by the day I hate
to say it but the insurrection act I get
a lot of people are upset about this and
I understand if a government sends
police in after their
people that's a problem but the thing
that really outrages the left gosh you
know you can NIC nary a window to be
found is a style thing guys it's a maybe
they went for the boards were put boards
were in that year in 2020 that's how the
meetings gonna look back on this boards
were in what does it say I love pandas
they are not racist they are black white
and Asian some albino black kid maybe a
mixed I don't really understand what
they're trying to say here but it's very
confusing messages so you should we
should add to it and they don't and they
don't screw pandas that's a real problem
the insurrection act but am i concerned
right now
no because of the reaction from the left
what they're most upset about where
Donald Trump gave his speech he was
talking about the insurrection act I'd
be looking there here doesn't matter
it's like in right and TV MGD what he's
talking about the insurrection act and
he's also encouraging the Second
Amendment or at least ensuring the
Second Amendment that's not a president
who wants to send the police force in
against his people that's a man who
wants to use the insurrection act to
protect his people and by the way it's
also why I'm a big fan of the Second
Amendment is that argument done now when
people say why do you need that man why
do you need that many rounds why do you
need a magazine
why can't you district Joe Biden just
have a double-barrel shotgun I don't
know did you see the video of the man
whose wife was being beaten by a 2x4
while they forced him to watch because
they beat him off with a 2x4 did you see
that that's the kind of evil that I
wouldn't know how to describe or expect
happening here in the United States out
in broad daylight like we saw yesterday
and guess what a double-barrel shotgun
is gonna do it when there's nine of them
and it's within his not only is it
within the man's within the bounds of
the law it is that man's duty to defend
his wife that's why you should have a
firearm you tell them to back up stop
beating my wife or the two by four and
then protect your wife you empty that
clip
and each other one else to back up or
you you start entering another clip is
that a call to violence no I am NOT I
absolutely don't want people to go out
and be vigilantes I want people to stay
home I want people to be safe want you
to obviously in these areas here you
have to board up your windows hope you
love livin in the city guys this is why
they're not gonna bring it to the
suburbs anytime soon because they're
armed Polk County made sure to that that
was a great statement from that Sheriff
what is your duty to protect your flock
I think right now it'll be interesting
to see when they pivot back to the
Second Amendment why do you need that
why don't you just call the cops
well first off you guys said the cops
were all racist but I I don't think
that's the case I think there's some bad
cops I think we need higher standards
for cops absolutely but I do think I
absolutely do think that people should
be able to protect themselves from let's
say a tyrannical government and police
force should that ever happen we're not
seeing that right now but that's what
the Second Amendment is for I think
there's a lot of things to get to that
oh that's another one right that fake
hate crime of the driver in Minneapolis
I can't remember his name foreign guy
like B yeah max Bialystock that wasn't
his real name what does it say shop
online support local oh that's a skip we
were gonna interview this guy but he
actually since obviously they're not
doing any business he had to go to
another location but yeah his business
was kicked in and by the way this is a
skate shop they don't necessarily have
the great greatest relationship with law
enforcement so that's a perfect example
where you probably have taken someone
who would sympathize with you and you've
turned them into enemies that driver in
Minneapolis right he was dismissed and
people say or the charges were dropped
people are demanding justice well you
know what happened if you go back and
watch that footage they said that he ran
over people you can find footage of them
saying he cheered ran over people who
called him the n-word now it was a
foreign truck driver
there was no barricade so he's driving
through the freeway which people had
effectively invaded and barricaded and
they all split apart and you can watch
this footage I can't bring it up right
now they all split apart and then when
they didn't continue splitting apart
there was a lady on her knees I believe
in the middle of the freeway and the
driver stopped well how was he rewarded
for his troubles he was
rag from a truck a semi-truck and beaten
within an inch of his life are you
looking at oh we got an answer for tag
over here okay so again we're working
now any crime this is what this is what
I hate seeing and this is how you breed
more racism unfortunately is when any
single crime or even no crime the truck
driver didn't drive over anyone but when
any crime is committed against someone
who happens to be black from someone who
happens to be white they want to label
it a hate crime a race crime so that
that what that builds up more resentment
and division and then you can justify an
to fuss showing up maybe we can ask this
gentleman here what what's going on what
he thinks let's see what's going on
breaks your heart to see this here in
the United States right now just want to
show you guys and of course obviously
the rioters are tired off of their crack
or meth hi we don't discriminate could
be meth could be crack could be heroin
could be Aaron that's the great divider
that's the great bridge is heroin
everyone loves heroin
this is crowd
hey man do you mind if s what's uh is
this your business here yet you had to
board it up this is your business
oh it is your business here oh did they
ask you to paint this here you paint you
says God told you to okay
it's actually very nice Louise is that
your painting
for who can you tell me about soda
[Music]
pulled a weapon on a police officer when
they had stopped okay right by the way
I'm receiving another we're not supposed
to social distancing right apparently
riots Kirk ovid so we know for sure if
he had a cell phone if we had a gun yeah
do we know which like has there been any
reporting the story to know what's true
because obviously been a lot of
misreporting out there on both sides
they went along with the police you know
it's true what the poky said they went
along with the police they wrote it in
the newspaper to say that it was true
that the man had a gun but it was never
the video or what happened was never
released to the public and the reason
why they say it was never released to
the public was because was because they
said it was too gruesome to show to
public here I was that to gruesome when
you look into the public network
entities that they show into the public
what ain't gruesome yeah talk about all
the right videos that they've been
putting out into the news for us to see
so how is this too gruesome why they
want why they won't put the evidence out
and show us what happened to this man
matter of fact right now we still
looking for the evidence like we now go
back he asked them where's the video
that shows that de Soto that he had a
cell phone right until we had a video
can I ask you something though because I
understand that you're leery of the
police they said he had a gun and you're
saying well why did they accept that
story right we should have some happen
I'm not saying why what I'm saying is
they so the video
we're happy they never sold the video
they never saw the video or the officer
who was shot home I never saw the video
that was on him yeah I read the story
they never saw the video so how are they
able to just just throw it away just
throw the whole case it was just like
come on now if it was a black man and
somebody say a black man stole the
president's daughter but then you got no
video video to show it anything to just
throw it away they finna go freeze down
every black man today found a
president's daughter so why isn't he
giving justice for this man well what if
justice what if he did have a gun
because - but if they're no hon second
but my point is like you said a lot of
people accepted the officers story we
wasted time with the wood is that's the
whole problem
Oh would it is no no we have tempered
the truth so like for example George
Floyd terrible the man has been charged
with third-degree murder right right
that's a good thing no it's not good
because they're happy no I'm not saying
it's good but I'm saying at least at
that point the officer has been held so
what would you Mars is the waters is the
message get out that Doug was not right
that's what matters well I think the
message is out do you think that
breaking windows and the looting gets
the message out do you think it hurts
the message all of it is the message
everything all of it is a part of the
message whether is looting rather is
painting on building whether is drawing
on t-shirts whether there is where
certain shoes all of it is the message
and it all measly gets out I think this
is I don't know the story exactly I
think this is beautiful I think I think
this well that's true but people can't
loot people can't commit crimes because
they're not a violation of other
people's right no they can't they should
but they have been they have been and
now people are looting both are crying
no and now people are rising up that's
what it is people just rising up it
ain't looted is this rising up I'm gonna
tell you is it is it is it just as when
the black man I got a doc or something
he ain't even do I say no it's not
justice
no it's not neither is looting and
rioting no I'm gonna tell you what
either a shooting innocent public what
is looting I'm gonna tell you what
breaking it so is getting treated
unfairly okay black people is getting
we built this country on our [ __ ]
backs every day we still get up and pay
taxes but yet we still get treated like
we are not human that's what's not fair
that's what's looting us putting our
time into the city and into this dating
into this world and yet we still getting
treated like we animals that's what's
looting so still in our time watch it
happen stealing our time still in our
time we could be spending with our
families instead of going out here and
working these jobs to pay taxes for the
same police officers we don't give a
[ __ ] about us that's why the people are
looting because you are sawing is that
there is no future without no peace
there is no future we we spare your the
people are sparing all the tyranny the
people who don't care all y'all who stay
in these high-rises and he's and he's
and he's very expensive buildings and
y'all hiding out they should be yeah
yeah y'all should be hiding because
y'all the ones who are turning our heads
to the to the to the mistreatment is
going on but what if they're not young
daughters getting spare right now
because we we the people are the people
in this world is strong y'all that we
want peace we we saw y'all they'll be
born a future that's why everything I
value that's shown peace on America
America was raised on the Bible that's
what it said right but how come the
people who saw car run America who said
it was ran off the Bible isn't not
treating the people like the Bible said
the people need to be treated well it
sounds like a lot of generalizations I
think some white people are and some
white people aren't man come now time
for some that's the problem that's the
problem bro this is the thing right here
everybody need to be held accountable I
can't really need to take action in
every nation because black people black
people have to take accountability every
time a white person call accountability
to me listen to me for a second I mean
listen every time a white person call
the police what they say a black man
meaning black people have to take
accountability so when these white
people is killing these officers white
people in it does accountability for
what white people do to church just like
black people take accountability every
time a black man do something what do
the news say black man black man is some
black man there but without a white man
do something no no and you better not
extra style to every time a white man do
something what they say oh man no yes
they do they'll never say white man let
me ask you this
that's not that's not fair Bodie I think
was how should I be held accountable
I'm trying to see what how I can do my
part what do you think how to do your
part this is what you do and you're not
righteous i'ma tell you this and I hope
you all get this on immigration if
you're not racist and you're a white
person of any other nationality or you
or anyone else besides black yeah and
you go home and you hear your prayers
and your people talk about our people
like we ain't nothing but when they go
to school they want to be best friends
with us and they want to be like us and
anyone listen to the music that we
produce and not a good thing I'm gonna
tell you something y'all need to speak
up and tell you our people to stop being
racist stop okay because being raised
because y'all sons not being racist
recorded because y'all since reporting
being raised sons and daughters lovers
sure our sons in your door let it come
to school they want to be like this okay
so stop stop telling them to be racist
just be quiet it says they don't be
racist
don't be raised don't be raised so don't
come out here and pretend in front of
your friends because y'all grouped up
and it's five white people and y'all
want to sit around and talk about black
people cuz they are in the wrong I'm
just asking you I think that don't be
bias well don't be how are you Bob I'm
telling I'm just saying I don't know if
it's you but it could be you you got the
same I don't know eluded but it could be
you but assuming it's nobody not here
talking about that though we're talking
about yes Gabriel ooh dude does your
name Gabriel or did you ask me is
Gabriel looted you me like mark angel so
that's not what we talking about what we
talking about
I'm Chuck I'll do we hold accountability
you hold accountability as a nation
that's what's important because that's
what's going on it's like I said and
every time your people oh that's pretty
racist don't be racist bro I'm gonna
tell you what if I said your people and
said you're all criminals that's
terrible what that is that's a fact 1900
Isis why do our people is the one who's
called the police and black people
that's not I don't call the police
listen funny people it's a black person
commits a crime for a second you can to
record me I
yeah no I'm asking you a humble enough
to stop talking hi y'all black people
about what they're going through but you
can't even humble yourself to stop you
talk motions and you want to waste my
time I'm not wondering I want to know
what weighs what you Legion listen I'm
listening listen yeah your people when
they call the police why are people well
yes when your wife's can put that
complexion call the police on the
blasting cap lesson they say black
people yeah so that means that nations
these young people do and that's not a
racist not all white people this listen
man stop interrupting me please well you
just said you keep interrupting me
please go ahead
your people white people is what I say
right that's not a racist comment that's
a fact you can't say you people do and
then say it not all white people are the
same thing not all white people this
time just like not all black people in
this talk
does the owner know that you're doing
this did you talk them about it is this
order graffiti okay is it order this
your business is this your business
thank you it's not your business
okay let's have someone call the police
about that if it's just find out if it's
a business what am i [ __ ] because
it's private property maybe the biggest
owner is fine okay it's allowing people
the vice president we allow busking and
we so who's a bit who's the name of this
business owner what's his name I don't
know is he ok with it
don't get behind me he's done this twice
the business owner what it was he's done
this twice he's done this twice of the
business is white privilege to try to
stop me it's vandalism
I think it's beautiful but how about
this I'll bring in a I'll bring in a
canvas how my coward I just something I
spoke with you you're a coward
really face me you a caller I'm facing
your own something my name is steven
crowder
you a cop what's your name where's Ben
coward what's your name
I'm Gabriel Thomas Gabriel turn you're
being a coward how am I being a coward
because I'm
there's also vandalism I wouldn't on my
business I own a business I wouldn't
allow it I just want to make sure that
this guy what does that mean yeah people
can be rich from being rich yeah being
rich how much trying to stop you from me
I want you to be rich so I hope you're
not people who - what about me you just
are you me and you trying to stop
something bigger than you you're bigger
than me
no what about 145 you this message is
bigger than you but you just supported
rioting and looting by okay let me ask
you this then what do you think about
the kickin end of Windows here star wear
nice boy Oh sounds pretty racist racist
yeah it sounds pretty racist cuz you
like a faker our Superman with that
weak-ass haircut yeah you look like a
fake wu-tang wannabe can I break balls
balls to black man from boom was right
yes
I'm trying to stop anyone from counting
crimes yeah I'm not trying to trap you
if that will call it if the business
owners cool
I have no problem no problem the
business our school was interrupted do
you think you what it is I'm sorry we
target is from you from me yes Steve
coward yeah there's no way to reason
with someone is somebody who will care
about slavery I would like it if you
back up yeah back up a lie I don't want
any problem you were representative
listen you how do you feel about the
looting and how do you feel about these
windows all can view it any comments not
put rice on us I mean you never coming
don't think it's wrong you can't just
say no violent looting thank you thank
you hope you have a good day this is and
this is the tough guy thing as you leave
right bye coward yeah that's it's
interesting that guy who only comes up
from behind you we'll call you a coward
and this is something that happens
there's a lot of these people and by
these people I mean just as much the
White City City Council Commission what
was it community commission let's look
that up and see what the community
Commission is exactly I'm willing to bet
that they're not an elected
authoritative body and it is interesting
that he refused to outright condemn any
looting whatsoever I mean this is pretty
remarkable to me this is clear as day
these areas are being destroyed what do
you say
if you call me back now tough guy and
this is the issue right that's one
individual but now let's imagine there's
thousands imagine there's thousands and
you're a police officer how do you deal
with that how do you deal with that
because you see when it's one person
right they're obviously afraid to be
violent and I don't think that was a
moral decision I think that was simply a
weight class decision but when they have
a mob of people they just start throwing
bodies at the cause you saw how that
started peacefully started asking about
it you people you people white people
you people they hate is unimaginable
I can't imagine saying you people
meaning blacks were sparing y'all think
of that for a second
you want to talk about entitlement white
privilege is there anything more
privileged than telling someone that
you're sparing them which means that you
have the right to take their life
because of what justification you people
the race so all white people according
to this man and not all black people
believe that I want to be really clear
all white people are being spared by
looting rioting activists and don't live
in a penthouse because that means that
you automatically deserve to get broken
into let's go look at the flyer those
are what what that he was painting yeah
time to get going I just want to see
this poster right here I just keep your
eyes ahead on swivel and by the way guys
I want to be really clear no one should
go out there and play tough guy I don't
care if you're Eddie Hall or Brian Shaw
or Daniel Cormier when you have a mob of
people it doesn't matter they cease to
be individuals it becomes a
shape-shifting amoeba where any and all
violence is conscionable for some reason
also black rifle dot-com slash trout or
entering the promo coach Crowder you get
20% off really could have used my black
rifle coffee this morning
unfortunately I put cream in it which is
racist
smashed up window there's not even a
window here Oh a car okay well you know
the car is a symbol of white privilege
and patriarchy okay so black visions
collective white privileges
I can go birding apparently not a fan of
the Goodyear wasn't Steve Martin's best
work I can go jogging I can relax in the
comfort of my home I can have a cell
phone I can leave a party to get to
safety I can play loud music I don't
understand what this is supposed to be
and then right here says not all blacks
are criminals not all whites are racist
not all cops are bad ignorance comes in
all colors that's something I can
entirely agree with barring the sweeping
broad generalities made afterward which
are incorrect and that's something that
is antithetical to what this gentleman
was saying over there in that all white
people you people let me be really clear
ok and I think we have to wrap this up
here when I say you people referring to
rioters that means anti-fur that means
black lives matter that means anybody
when I say you people meaning people
committing crimes it means people
committing any crime the division right
now is between law-abiding citizens and
people who want chaos rioting and
looting this has been good morning mud
club tomorrow we're gonna be talking
about social media the executive order
appreciate you guys taking the time I'm
gonna go enjoy some beats
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]